- All right everybody, welcome
to the "Kelly Clarkson Show."
Give it up for My Band Y'all,
and their incredible dancers.
(audience applauding)
(Kelly clapping)
That was "She Used to be Mine"
from Waitress The Musical.
I've always loved that song,
but there's actually a special reason
that I sing it today.
Check out this tweet,
it's the sweetest thing from the account
of Waitress The Musical.
They wrote requesting that
I sing it before the end
of their Broadway run.
Sara Bareilles, who I love,
who is an original cast member
even retweeted it, so I
couldn't pass up the invite.
So we have actually, the actress
that's currently starring
is Jenna and Waitress joining us.
So let's say hi to Sierra Renée y'all.
(Audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Hi, oh my gosh!
We're so happy to have you.
- I'm so happy to be here. Thank you.
- Well, I'm so honored that
y'all wanted me to sing.
First of all, that song, I love that song.
It's so beautiful, by the way.
God, so empowering to sing,
feels like, I've gotta raw
moment every time you sing it.
But what's it been like, coming
back to play this character?
- It's been wild and
strange and beautiful.
I obviously like everyone
else in the theater community,
so missed performing and
telling these beautiful stories.
But to be able to step into this story
which is just so wonderful and so humane,
and of course with this
incredible music by Sara Bareilles
and this script by Jessie
Nelson, it's a dream come true.
- Oh my gosh. Well you have
a few shows left, right?
- Yes, we have two more
days and four more shows.
So grab your tickets and come on.
- Oh my gosh you must be having
this feeling of like bitters sweet,
'cause you love doing it,
but at the same time, you're
like it's that finish line
that's kind of cool too.
Are you kind of both feelings right now?
- Yeah, absolutely that,
it's always sad to say bye
to any show, especially
one that's so meaningful
and powerful as this one
and also like so fun.
- Yeah
- And so much
of a family that we've
built together, the cast,
but yeah, always moving on to
the next thing as an actor.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you for being on the show.
(Kelly clapping)
(kelly laughing)